[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 y ya me Acompañé en el
estudio Marta Moya Marta bienvenida
Bueno mañana de jueves y abrimos nuestra
revista de prensa con una interesante
investigación de verdad está muy buena
una exclusiva que ha hecho el periódico
estadounidense de Times que recoge los
audios de los soldados rusos en el
frente de batalla durante el mes de
marzo no casi que al inicio de esta
invasión rusa así de Raúl buenos días
recogemos esta investigación en
exclusiva que presenta el New York Times
justo en este momento donde las
escaladas de la tensión por parte del
crimen están disparadas el New York
Times lanza esta exclusiva que titula
Putin is the full Putin es tonto vamos a
traducirlo así las llamadas
interceptadas revelan a un ejército ruso
desordenado estas llamadas es como
decías están recogidas desde el mes de
marzo y son llamadas hechas desde los
soldados en el frente de batalla a
familiares y amigos y Pues un poco la
crudeza del terreno Cómo están perdiendo
esta batalla en el frente y están
criticando además a los líderes del
kremlin en las primeras semanas de la
ofensiva y diciendo Bueno pues que la
estrategia planteada por el gobierno
ruso no estaba siendo efectiva en el
terreno recordemos que al principio de
la invasión rusa el objetivo inicial del
kremlin era tomar kiev la capital de
manera rápida Pero eso no se estaba
cumpliendo en el terreno dice este
artículo que desde las trincheras desde
casas ocupadas y refugios en bucha en
estos suburbio al oeste de kiev de la
capital estos soldados burlaron en la
prohibición de hacer llamadas no
autorizadas y se contactaron con
familiares con novias esposas y amigos
para para decirles cómo estaba siendo
todo en el terreno pero Marta digamos
que dicen los audios Cómo llegó además
el New York Times a ellos o sea como los
recopilaron Pues claro probable los
soldados rusos no sabían que estaban
siendo grabados por la inteligencia
ucraniana Y esos audios llegaron al New
York Times que ha estado dos meses
editando los verificándolos Pues con
teléfono ruso redes sociales otros
perfiles y han bueno han elaborado este
Bueno este reportaje en exclusiva donde
como decimos se revelan audios muy
crudos que critican al gobierno de Putin
escuchemos el primer audio
bueno Y también según lo que muestra la
investigación o Marta los soldados rusos
ya sabían desde el inicio que esta
guerra no iba a ser fácil además como
todo el mundo Pensaba así es hablamos de
bucha este suburbio en el oeste de kiev
y los militares relatan que la situación
allí en ese suburbio era muy complicada
como después han revelado en la
comunidad internacional hablando de
crímenes de guerra escuchemos
estas llamadas pertenecen a unidades de
la fuerza aérea y de la guardia nacional
rusa y como revelan pues destacar a un
ejército desordenado que no sabe muy
bien Cuál es la estrategia en estas
primeras semanas de la invasión rusa
Ucrania y que muchos de ellos ni
siquiera sabían que se estaban
enfrentando a una guerra de estas
magnitudes y de y no sabían a lo que se
estaban O sea que no sabían que habían
recibido este entrenamiento tan corto
para esta guerra de esta magnitud
escuchemos
muy viejo
también estos audios Marta de los
soldados revelan fuertes críticas al
presidente de Vladimir Putin y la
estrategia del kremlin no Así es son
audios de todo tipo de opiniones no pero
que también se centran en Putin y en el
kremlin y en Cómo han definido esta
estrategia no expresan que bueno
opiniones que en Rusia estarían
totalmente prohibidas y por eso el New
York Times como solo cita los nombres de
pila y elude el nombre de los familiares
para proteger sus identidades escuchemos
mucho inglés
esta investigación que es mucho más
extensa de lo que les estamos mostrando
pues revela estos errores estratégicos y
las quejas de los soldados por la falta
de suministros y dicen bueno que han
sacado negocios y casas en Ucrania y que
muchos de ellos se quisieran retirar
cuando regresaran a Rusia además
critican la estrategia del crimen de
tomar kiev la capital y dicen que esta
estrategia está totalmente mal planteada
escuchemos mínimo
[Aplausos]
Marte impresionante estos audios también
que dan cuenta un poco de la
desorganización y también pues la
resistencia ucraniana que no hay que
dejarla a un lado ya más de seis meses
de guerra todavía sigue resistiendo
Marta Gracias mañana con más revista de
prensa mañana más Raúl
y pasamos a saludar